mélange de fitness et d'arts martiaux
comme le kickboxing ou le taekwendo
l'aerobox est un cocktail d'étonnant et
lorsque l'on n pas habitué les coup de
point sont très vite moins énergi c'est
le seul sport de l'année je ti pas le
coup c'est horrible mais vous trouvez ça
sympa oui oui oui c'est très bien c'est
un petit peu intensif mais c'est bien
c'est surtout le menu parfait pour
oublier le stress du travail par
batterie de coup de pied dans le vide
toute la convivialité du cours et le
dynamisme de Sylvie et ça va vous tenz
le ch
je oui oui ça va bien je vous remercie
c'est on tiendra le coup c'est un cours
qui est très ludique qui plaît
énormément justement au public femme
parce que il y a une dépense d'énergie
c'est c'est pas très compliqué et voilà
c'est un défouloir après le travail qui
plaît beaucoup à l'origine l'aerobox
était une activité physique créée pour
l'agente féminine mais en cherchant bien
au fond de la salle quelques curieux s
essayent non sans difficulté c'est mon
je suis fumeur donc le cardio c'est
vraiment mon point
fa ça
VO exceptionnellement ce cours était
gratuit mercredi dernier dans le cadre
de la Semaine de la femme à
Man